LAURENCE MORONEY: Hey guys.
Can we get a photo
just for the scrapbook?
I mean, we just found this
lovely picnic table out
beside a parking lot, and I
really want to get a picture.
So OK.
Everybody, just show
me the pearly whites
on the count of three.
One, two, three.
Brian, you blinked.
LIZ: Man.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Come on
guys, it's not that hard.
You ready?
One, two, three.
Everybody looking good, and Liz.
You're frowning.
LIZ: What?
That was my smile.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Just give us a smile.
You've got a beautiful smile.
OK everybody, and set.
Ready.
And one, two, three.
Yeah.
Thank you.
It can be hard to get
pictures of people right.
And the more you try, the
more frustrating it can be.
Now, being able to detect
faces and their activity
can make that much easier, and
it opens up a whole new realm
of possibilities.
I'm Laurence Moroney
and I'm here today
to talk about the Vision APIs
that ship with Google Play
Services and how
you can use them.
Now using these, you
have access to some
of the great features that can
turn your pictures from this
to this, and maybe even this.
Now of course, you're not
just limited to pictures.
This API will allow
you to build apps
that can do all
kinds of fun things
with detected faces
and facial activities.
Think about the things that
this could do for your app.
Maybe you can create awesome
avatars from your users' faces,
or you can do silly
things to their faces.
Or maybe you can
create games that
are controlled by the
expression on a face,
like smiling to shoot.
Now the Vision APIs
make facial detection
in a picture, a video, or a live
camera preview really simple.
But one thing to note is that
it's facial detection and not
facial recognition.
The APIs will detect
the areas in the image
where there are faces, but
not who those faces belong to.
You might see some
familiar faces here.
And the app has no
idea who they are.
How many can you recognize?
I can tell you it's a
lot more than the API.
Now one thing is
that it's really
good at detecting human faces.
So sorry, Bucky, no hat for you.
In addition to
that, it will also
detect various parts of the
face that it calls landmarks.
No, not that kind of landmark.
Landmarks are well known
parts of the human face.
And here you can
see some examples.
Where a face is
detected, the coordinates
for things such as the
bottom of the mouth,
the base of the nose, or the
centers and tips of the eyes
will become available.
So for example, if I wanted to
give this nice lady a mustache,
it would be easy to plot the
center of the tache using
the edges of her mouth, the
base of her nose, and her lips.
Something like this.
Yep, that's tachetastic.
Now beyond just seeing
the landmarks on the face,
the Vision APIs also detect
activity on the face.
So maybe your
subject is blinking,
or maybe they're winking,
or maybe they're smiling.
Well, there's an API for that.
Almost.
Now the face doesn't have to
be directly facing the camera.
The API is smart enough
to detect a face even
at different angles
and inclinations.
Now think about the things
you could do by turning
your face into a controller.
Maybe wink your
left and right eyes
to move a spaceship left or
right, and smile to shoot.
The possibilities are limited
only by your imagination.
You can learn more
about the Vision APIs
and the great types
of apps that you
can build with them on
the Google Developer
site at these links.
Thank you, and don't forget
to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]